after that first trip I was hooked you
know right right right from that and and
not so much with the rebuilding which is
what I thought that I would be excited
for when I went down there but when I
saw how the the poorest people and the
darkest people of the city were the ones
were hurt the worst and who since then
have gotten the least support it kind of
forced me to look at my own city and my
own home in a different light and so I
started to look at new york and i saw
and i looked at maps and there's all
kinds of statistics and you can see that
new york city is just as segregated as
new orleans is by class and by race and
pretty much anything else that you want
to look up and you know I and I
personally live on 94th and Lexington on
the east side and if you go to 96 street
and you go to Park Avenue you can stand
on that one street and turn and look
south and you'll see the upper east side
which is the wealthiest district in the
entire United States in the middle of
the yeah I mean everybody there is rich
everybody there is white in the middle
of the streets you see these little
islands with grass and trees and all
these nice things and you can literally
turn around and look north you have East
Harlem and instead of the grass the
islands you have the train that comes
out of the ground and goes above ground
there and look the Spanish Harlem has
the highest concentration of public
housing in the US and it's one of the
poorest areas of the United States it
has some of the highest asthma rates
diabetes rates crime rates etc you know
so on and so forth and so I saw I
started to think what happens if Katrina
or any hurricane hits New York City you
know what neighborhoods would be flooded
what neighborhoods would they protect
you know where would the levees begin
what would have you know what would
happen which way with the water go at
ninety-sixth Street and you know my own
home so when I saw that I knew that I
had to keep going and so our school did
two more trips which I also went on and
then the school actually stopped having
trips and at first I was devastated cuz
I thought oh my god I don't know what
I'm ever going to go to New Orleans
again but then it hit me and said you
know I don't we don't need our school
like why does our school have to
facilitate these trips so a bunch of us
got together and decided that we wanted
to go down on our own and that was the
summer after my sophomore year and so we
got together and we decided to go and we
planned
trip and everything and then actually
the night before we left I like if we
want to be official and like actually do
something we just need a name we just
need some sort of title and it just like
hit me in the middle of the night I
didn't sleep the night before we went it
just hit me New York to New Orleans
coalition I didn't even know what
coalition meant it just kind of sounded
good at the time but uh so it hit me and
so we just traveled under that name and
then over the course of the next six or
seven months we got a non-profit status
and built a network and find plan one
more official trip when once we were a
non-profit with about 35 kids from the
my school the beacon school and since
then things have just kind of snowballed
and we've gotten bigger and bigger and
expanded way beyond our school and it's
uh it's gone it's been pretty exciting
since then
eventually there was a lack of support
from our school which was it was hurtful
considering that our school was the
people you know was what took me the
very first time and so to lose that
support was difficult to kind of get
over but you know and every and
everybody looks at us as kids as
students and most of us were sophomores
and maybe juniors at the time and looked
at us saying like you run a non-profit
like how you don't know what you're
doing you're not going to be able to do
this and we're talking about you know
changing the world and everything and
you know every adult that we knew for
the most part just kind of said all
right you know they humorous maybe but
you know never take us seriously so that
was always a little difficult but you
know every step of the way we've kind of
proving people wrong and that's that's
at this point I kind of love it I love
when somebody you know says oh you can't
do this and then it just kind of adds
that extra challenge and like reason to
do it now we haven't really failed that
many of our plans yet I guess another
major barrier has been finances because
the beacon the most of the beacon trips
and our first couple trips were very
white because much of our network of
people that we were able to do outreach
to were white and if we had extended
beyond that and and wealthy white
students and you know it turned into
whoever could pay for the trip could go
and if we're discussing like combating
racism and classism it doesn't really
make sense just to take kids who can
afford to go and you know it's a
relatively expensive trip so we've
really pushed hard to find to do
fundraising so that we have the money to
pay for kids to go and this past
februari we finally did it like we
finally had a really really diverse trip
in every way based on race income
schools we had kids from 11 different
schools there and so that's been our
biggest challenge and it's going to
continue to be such but you know we're
we're working on it we're finding new
inventive ways to to get money together
you